An important application of the
central limit theorem is
in the approximate calculation
of the binomial probabilities.
Here is what is involved.
We start with random
variables--
Xi--
that are independent.
And they have the same
distribution.
They're all Bernoulli
with parameter p.
We add n of those random
variables, and the resulting
random variable, Sn, we know
that it has a binomial PNF
with parameters n and p.
We also know its mean, and
we do know its variance.
What the central limit theorem
tells us, in this case, since
we're dealing with the sum of
independent identically
distributed random variables,
is the following.
If we take this random variable
here that we have
been denoting by Zn, which is a
standardized version of Sn--
we subtract the mean of Sn and
divide by the standard
deviation--
this random variable has a CDF
that approaches as n goes to
infinity, the CDF of
a standard normal.
So let us use what we now
know to calculate some
probabilities.
Let us fix some parameters.
n is 36.
p is 0.5.
And we wish to calculate the
probability that Sn is less
than or equal to 21.
Now, in this case, we can
calculate it exactly using the
binomial formula.
The probability of being less
than or equal to 21 is the sum
of the probabilities of all
the numbers from 0 to 21.
And this is the probability
of obtaining a number k.
And by calculating this
expression, we obtain this
number, which is the
exact answer.
Now, let us proceed using the
central limit theorem.
We are interested in this
probability, but we will use
the fact about the CDF of this
related random variable.
So the first step is
to calculate n
times p, which is 18.
The second step is to calculate
this denominator
here, which in our case
evaluates to 3.
Now, since we know something
about the CDF of this random
variable, what we need to do
is to take this event and
rewrite it in terms of
this random variable.
So we have the event of
interest, which is that Sn is
less than or equal to 21.
This is the same as the event
that Sn minus 18 is less than
or equal to 21 minus 18.
And it's the same as this event
here, where we divide
both sides by 3.
Now, what we have here is the
probability that this random
variable Zn is less than
or equal to 1.
But now, Zn is approximately a
standard normal, so we can use
here the CDF of the standard
normal distribution,
which is Phi of 1.
And at this point, we look at
the tables for the normal
distribution.
We'll find this entry here.
And this gives us an
answer of 0.8413.
This is a pretty good
approximation of the exact
answer, which is 0.8785.
But it is not a great
approximation.
It is off by about four
percentage points.
Can we do better than that?
It turns out that we can get
a better approximation.
And let us see how
this can be done.
Recall that we approximated
this probability using the
central limit theorem and found
this numerical value.
But we make an observation that
this probability is equal
to this probability here.
Why is that?
Sn is an integer random
variable.
Therefore, if I tell you that
it is strictly less than 22,
I'm also telling you that
it is 21 or less.
Therefore, this event here is
the same as that event here.
And therefore, their
probabilities are the same.
So instead of using the central
limit approximation to
calculate this probability,
let us follow the same
procedure but try to calculate
this probability here.
And this probability here
is equal to the
probability that Sn minus--
we subtract the mean, divide
by the standard
deviation of Sn--
is strictly less than 22 minus
18 divided by 3, which is the
probability that the random
variable that we denote by Zn,
which is this expression here,
is strictly less than 22
minus 18 over 3.
And this is 1.33.
Now, at this point, we pretend
that Zn is a standard normal
random variable--
the probability that the
standard normal is less than a
certain number.
This is the standard normal CDF
evaluated at that number.
And then we look up at the
normal tables at 1.33 and we
find this value of 0.9082.
Now, we compare this value
with the exact
answer for this problem.
And we see that we
again missed it.
Using this approximation to
this quantity gave us an
underestimate of this number.
Now, we obtained an
overestimate.
The true value is somewhere
in the middle.
So this suggests that we may
want to do something that
combines these two alternative
choices here.
But before doing that, it's
good to understand what
exactly have we be
doing all along.
What we're doing is
the following.
We have the PMF of the binomial
centered at 18, which
is the mean.
It's a discrete random
variable.
But when we use the central
limit theorem, we pretend that
the binomial is normal, but
while we keep the same mean
and variance.
Now, when we calculate
probabilities, if we want to
find the discrete probability
that Sn is less than or equal
to 21, which is the sum of these
probabilities, what we
do is we look at the area
under the normal
PDF from 21 and below.
In the alternative approach,
when we use the central limit
theorem to approximate the
probability of this event, we
go to 22, and we look at the
event of falling below 22.
This means that we're looking at
the area from 22 and lower.
So in one approach, this
particular region is not used
in the calculation.
That's what we did here.
But in the second approach, it
was used in the calculation.
Should it be used or not?
It makes more sense to use only
part of this solid region
and assign it to the calculation
of the probability
of being at 21 or less.
Namely, we can take the mid
point here, where the mid
point is at 21.5, and calculate
the area under the
normal PDF only going
up to 21.5.
What this amounts to is looking
at this particular
event here.
Now, this event is, of course,
identical to this event that
we have been considering,
because again, Sn is a
discrete random variable that
takes integer values.
But when we approximate it by
a normal, it does make a
difference whether we
write the event
this way or that way.
So here, we're going to obtain
the probability that the
standardized version
of Zn is less than.
We follow the same calculation,
but now we have
21.5 minus 18 divided by 3.
And this number here is 1.17.
And using the central limit
theorem calculation, this is
the CDF of the standard normal
evaluated at 1.17, which we
can go and look up in the
normal table to find
the value of 0.8790.
And now, we notice that this
value is remarkably close to
the true value.
It is much better as an
approximation that what we
obtained using either this
choice or that choice.
And since this approximation
is so good, we may consider
even using it to approximate
individual probabilities of
the binomial PMF.
Let's see what that takes.
Let us try to approximate, as
an example, the probability
that Sn takes a value
of exactly 19.
So what we will do will be to
write the event that Sn is
equal to 19 as the event that Sn
lies between 18.5 and 19.5.
In terms of the picture that
we were discussing before,
what we are doing, essentially,
is to take the
area under the normal PDF that
extends from 18.5 to 19.5 and
declare that this area
corresponds to the discrete
event that our binomial random
variable takes a value of 19.
Similarly, if we wanted to
calculate approximately the
value of the probability that
Sn takes a value of 21, we
would consider the area
under the normal PDF
from 20.5 to 21.5.
So let us now continue
with this approach.
We do the usual calculations,
which is to express this event
in terms of standardized
values.
That is, we subtract throughout
the mean of Sn and
divide by standard deviation.
So what we obtain here is the
standardized version of Sn.
And that has to be, now, less
than or equal to 19.5 minus 18
divided by 3, which is the
probability that our
standardized random variable
lies between 0.17 and 0.5.
And now, if we pretend that Zn
is a standard normal random
variable, which is what the
central limit theorem
suggests, this is going to be
equal to the probability that
the standard normal is less than
or equal to 0.5 minus the
probability that it
is less than 0.17.
And if we look up those entries
in the normal tables,
what we find is an answer of
0.6915 minus this number,
which evaluates to 0.124.
And what is the exact answer if
we were to use the binomial
probability formulas?
The exact answer is remarkably
close to what we obtained in
our approximation.
This example illustrates a more
general fact that this
approach of calculating
individual entries of the
binomial PMF gives very
accurate answers.
And in fact, there are
theorems, there are
theoretical results to this
effect, that tell us that this
way of approximating--
asymptotically, as n goes
to infinity and
in a certain regime--
does give us very accurate
approximations.